the pact act you met a kid named Maddox
maple tell us how did you come to meet
this guy actually was through Zack my
brother I was living out in Cleveland
training a gym up there and getting
ready for when I was just an amateur
fighter trying to find my way to the pro
ranks and become a world champion so I
was going moving you know I have my city
and trying to go and further myself and
better myself
so I kind of stayed out of a small town
talk but and you know obviously staying
with Zack Zack was working in a coal
mine in the in the area so he was still
around the small town talk knew the
everything that was going on would keep
me informed like oh man Johnny dude he's
back in jail you know talk to me I'll be
talking and he said hey man you should
do a hear about that Maddox family the
maple family and I said no I didn't any
explained to me was this family this
five year old was diagnosed with
leukemia you know it's like I hit me and
just right in the feelgood's because I
have a sister the same age as Maddox and
they kind of just you notice for
whatever one has just first spoke about
it kind of just hit me right there was
not even known the family knowing the
child and he say you should do like a
benefit your next place donate the the
tickets and the sell shirts and get the
town you know kind of the back his fight
and then met the family after two weeks
he came back he was able to have
visitors after he is you know first
those of chemo and he was cleared to get
home and just start the process of
fighting this horrible disease and so I
come there and I see this little kid him
he looks you know just his whole world
was 360 you know spun around and yeah
you know it was going in for a burst
appendix he thought you know what you
know he's got a trach and a port his
chest he's getting his first dose of
chemo so yeah and I look at the kid and
I'm just like man this kid he had you
know big beautiful eyes I mean just but
I just tell he had that bat look you can
tell when you look at Mike when he
fights me look at these other fighters
that are great you see that look before
battle and that glossed over look like
determination you know you're right
focus and I saw that and I was like man
I just knew that I started to the
parents after I got to know him you know
like I just I just I know this kid's
gonna beat this disease I just get I can
just tell he's he's a warrior I can just
you know you know I can just I can just
feel that and you know meaning
that time and getting stay with them
learned a story we did the the benefit
the you know donations to his family and
just stayed in touch with like like
reaching out them he would come to all
my fight to his goal was to walk me out
to one of my fight that's what he wanted
to do but he was never healthy enough
become the chemo kept hurting his legs
he was a wheelchair meeting him and it
was a five year you know battle of five
and a half years we've noted Noah Maddox
and through his ups and downs in his
days that he wanted to give up I leaned
on him with my training and fighting you
know trying to make it to the UFC
because millions of kids and people
fighters all across the the world or
China that's what they wanted to do is
become the UFC champion and that was my
goal and and my nexus goal was just to
walk me down to the Octagon that was his
sole goal like he like for that he
fought for that you know I kept fighting
for it I can't wait to walk young girls
were accountable to each other yeah I
mean we were getting signed to the UFC
no no and bringing him there and seeing
him Wow
yeah just and then the UFC caught wind
of our story and granted him to walk
down to the octan when I fought for my
first world title I was like hand in
hand with him and I just felt invincible
that time like I was like nothing can
stop this is this is meant to be this is
my mouth you know I had like the most
flawless performance I was in the flow
state and just everything was lining up
in my life and you know so it was a
great it was a great night you know not
only because I want she was everyone was
so happy and what we finally I got to
put the belt around his waist and then
make sure you know where you know after
that a lot of stuff happens you know a
fast pace after wearing a world title
and got approached about doing a book I
never thought that it was gonna be
something this big I thought no I mean
like I look at man just doing something
yeah I just like felt right never yard
spear when I got offered a lot of book
and the movie I'm like wow this is this
is crazy and then with the reason why I
want to do it and push forward because I
feel like his fight matters his his his
story needs to be shared you know tell
how many people are affected by this
horrible disease that he members they
lutely
they've lost family members or mothers
or brothers or sons or daughters through
this disease that this is a kid that you
know was just five years old you know
can go through any of that yeah is it
with the power of belief Leon himself
and having a purpose fun you know I
focus on something like myself like my
lighter in the tunnel was being
champion that's what kept me you know
from that you know getting hooked on
drugs from going down the wrong path
from just being a [ __ ] up was that mean
a world champion are you I'm you know
our worlds collide our you know crash
course kind of like a pivotal time with
me Oh getting a lot of bar fights and
stabbed and other stuff in Hemel going
through chemo you know finally I have
cancer we kind of met that time when
there were low points and kind of just
raised up all the way to the top became
the best in the world you know world
champions and you know couldn't do
without that kid you know it's amazing
yeah it's awesome so incredible how's he
doing no he's great he's 11 years old
amazing for years in remission yeah so
it says last year you know August August
22nd would be his fifth year of mission
so hoping then you know it surprised him
with a huge like and I just I want to
get making something just just special
for a little kid
[Music]